LSpeaker 1: et's speak next to Isaac from
Wyoming.
Isaac from Wyoming, please.
Speaker 3: Hello, David.
Thanks for taking my call.
I appreciate you taking a chance on somebody
from Wyoming.
I love Wyoming.
Thank you.
Have you been to Wyoming?
Never.
Speaker 1: But I would like to go.
I hear that, you know, there's like a big
sky there and stuff.
Speaker 3: Yeah, Big Sky and bad politics.
OK.
So I guess my question is it's kind of silly
because I sort of already know the answer,
and honestly, I just jumped in here and am
admittedly not completely prepared, but my
question is, do you have any plans in the
future to sort of hire your own investigative
journalist, which I have seen you've been
doing somewhat recently and sort of just expand
into a legitimate news outlet?
Speaker 1: Well, we are completely illegitimate
currently, and so your concern is certainly
warranted.
Will we ever have an air of legitimacy?
That's fair.
Many people ask me that that that that's a
fair question.
No, I know what you're saying.
I mean, we're a commentary and analysis show.
We're not a news reporting show, and we don't
we don't pretend otherwise.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm open.
I'm always open to considering anything.
I just think we have to think about, like
as a small organization, if we hire one investigative
reporter, what can we really do something
that we feel is meaningful and we can feel
good about compared to entities with just
overwhelmingly more resources, but I have
no opposition to it in principle.
Speaker 3: Awesome.
Other than that.
One more question.
As someone who's more left leaning and a red
state, what types of things would you recommend
for people in my situation to sort of influence
politics in the state and push it towards
the left sport
Speaker 1: in many red states where there's
like a tradition of voting for Republicans,
but people are actually open to different
ideas.
Getting involved in ballot initiatives can
be really effective because rather than saying,
Hey, vote for this Democrat, which maybe isn't
going to happen, you can find ballot initiatives
that are reasonable moves to the left that
will not seem as scary to a Republican electorate.
And so I would look at getting involved in
ballot initiatives, whether they be about
campaign finance, the environment, whatever's
important to you.
Speaker 3: Awesome, yeah.
Actually, Naomi, there there is an ongoing
effort to create a ballot initiative to legalize
marijuana that has thus failed so far because
the signature requirements are so big, you
know, we just can't get their signature requirements.
Yes.
In any case, thanks for talking to me and
I love the show.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you so much.
Let us know if you make any headway there
in in Wyoming